oh I came to this video plain umbrella
from from France Jacques Brel probably
but not the one is dead for him what a
long time now but probably a fan of him
okay we got the been known you were
normally go with this nigeria line some
good results with that okay I always
want to prevent this yam the early age
five possible hmm interesting that I
didn't know that this was possible um
what to do now maybe just 92 it's not
ideal f3 looks a bit weak though bit
weakening
yeah I'm not sure 92 looks a bit clumsy
yeah always funnier this this h-bond at
it it's always a bit a bit of a very for
white some some Queen 2g for a2g to mate
but that's not happening that quickly
now I want to play Knight to c4
therefore i'm covering this wow yeah
this is a very very ambitious move g5
okay 95 m I need to return him probably
need to do this in any case so can do it
right away check yeah it's obviously
very tricky position its I don't think
any good for black his King long term
will be the more problematic piece but
it's tricky to play how to do that if
I've look a format be an idea yeah I
need to I'd like to play against the the
bishop he obviously f4 is not so great I
belief maite can't get something on the
Jeep are at the moment it's not so
apparent how you should get towards that
I get to my king
and five of course was something that
you can try but yeah of course at the
end of blacks king is totally totally
naked my idea is very obvious I want to
sacrifice the exchange on deform
no but it's not easy to to to fight for
black what what what should he do when I
get this in I mean his most important
piece is gone and yeah I think now he's
taking some time to realize that all
this was at least risky what he did I'm
not totally sure about the objective
value but I don't really think it's
great for lucky
that's difficult to prevent OOP deform
okay so um f-4s some not directly
threatening 96 still seems to still
seems to keep the position going firm I
but rook rook g1 okay I'm going for that
even the other moves were interesting I
didn't think about this one only 96 mmm
okay let's use them the g file one idea
could be Bishop to h5 rook takes rook g8
will win big material
and one idea that she has is to to give
it back on c3 and then take you for of
it I'm not sure that it's good at the
moment
that's to be honest a bit shocking this
should be possible my t4 is inviting
this night 22 to the attack really wow
okay error maybe I have something better
but this looks good night f6 is not so
great probably
yeah 2g3 maybe maybe 2 g-3 checking f5 I
mean I also have just Bishop d2 to see
three at some not bad okay so playing
for for those tricks iam rook g3 Bishop
e3
time morning yeah I don't have any time
that's a problem rookie one I don't I
don't know but it covers the YouTube
bishop and maybe allows to play on the e
how later it also takes a five we should
be 5 mm what was interesting but for
take now what does this reply rook c1
probably just just those funky and funky
tactics check check then whoops it to at
the end or maybe
Jeff yeah just just a good end game yes
that's what I want to keep it keep it
under control the whole thing check
check check okay that's a win now the
Jeep of the protected pawns will do the
trick check check check game drunk yeah
i was i was too slow relieving the shame
not winning this is really a shame yeah
it was was very very complicated yeah
right out of the opening this um yeah
well this might be playable but just
with this g5 i don't i don't don't think
so I have my doubts maybe you can do it
but it rather quickly developed into a
very good position for wide no this was
clear and after the exchange think I
mean white white should be really good
here just the pawn further for the
computer okay but around here this looks
really really good Bishop h5 is stronger
okay em this was of course an idea but
okay nighty for getting the night until
the tech didn't look bad as well yeah
that seems that i'm at least keeping oh
he could have one yeah black would've
won
ruki one was a mistake okay Bishop tutu
was good this was a mistake he could
take him and here and this this is
unfortunately losing then night to h6
with the night kami to g4 okay yeah now
of course check it's an it's only
question how how much advantage
destroyed have check check we went to
this end game which is check check check
very very winning but okay it was just
tricky to do with the time I'm four
seconds up though yeah sometimes my
practical problem is I still want to
play good moves and not just win on time
I can take the why don't I take the
night as really sick yeah sometimes
still try to play good moves instead of
just winning on time which is of course
possible move any any nonsense and TM he
has so has saved himself oh wow okay
thanks for watching